but the really cool thing is it has to
do with the
the infinite fun that you're referring
to which is our brain seems to be very
limited and like you said
computational so very plastic very
plastic yeah yeah so it's a it's a com
interesting combination but the the
interesting open question is the limits
of that neuroplasticity like
how how flexible is that thing
because we don't we haven't really
tested it we know about the experiments
where they they put like a pressure pad
on somebody's head
and had a visual transducer pressurize
it and somebody slowly learned to see
yep that's like it's especially at a
young age if you throw a lot at it
like what what can it uh
uh can it completely so can you like
arbitrarily expand it with computing
power so
get connected to the internet directly
somehow yeah the answer is probably yes
so the problem with biology and ethics
is like there's a mess there
like us humans are perhaps
unwilling to take risks
in uh into directions that are full of
uncertainty
so it's like 90 of the population is
unwilling to take risks the other 10
is rushing into the risks unaided by any
infrastructure whatsoever
and you know and that that's where all
the fun happens in
you know society there's been huge
transformations yeah
in the last you know a couple thousand
years
you